taking pride in your home in your
neighborhood one of the key parts of
home ownership and one viewer reached
out during our eight news now Community
call in for help Mary Jane billiesza
headed to a North Las Vegas neighborhood
not too far from Kerry and Revere and
has more on what they want to see done
[Music]
this is the area off of Carrie and
inglestad where residents say they would
like to see Improvement in their
neighborhood here you can see trash
weeds and debris
all I'm asking is that we do something
with the neighborhood Carrie Richard
first bought her house back in the 1960s
and keeps her home well maintained by
cutting the grass and trees Richard said
she reached out to the city of North Las
Vegas to see if they can do the same
which you can see that it is not kept
and I never get a call back codeine
Postman I've called them probably five
or six times and they haven't done
anything and I just think we need to go
further with this I said but we need a
sidewalk if we're not going to get a
sidewalk please enlarge the street this
lot is owned by several different
Property Owners a spokesperson for the
city of North Las Vegas says sidewalks
are determined by the property owner
when the parcel of land is developed
Judy Clark has grown up in this area and
bought this house across the street in
1998. Clark said four years ago she
reached out to Mayor Pamela goins-brown
for help when she was still in North Las
Vegas council member she did tell me
that it was not in the budget at the
time oh to beautify the neighborhood she
said it's not in the budget I say well
when would it be in a budget she said
that she didn't know and then I think I
talked with her one more time I talk
with her twice and um
it's not in the budget Richard says her
mission is to raise awareness about what
could be done to revamp her neighborhood
in a community where she lives and loves
we've really been left behind because I
don't feel as fair to me to be a
homeowner
who has six for since 1967.
this is 23. we should I should have some
kind of update in my neighborhood
because I'm trying to keep it up
yep she's been waiting for a while eight
news now did reach out to the city of
North Las Vegas people who live there
are advised to reach out to code
enforcement to see if and when their
concerns will be addressed